What makes organized crime strong?
It is very well-connected across borders.
Criminal leaders can cooperate
over long distances,
build efficient logistics
and hide their wealth
across many jurisdictions.
How do we know about this?
One of the reasons is journalists.
We are often the first ones
to reveal the enormous schemes
of organized crime networks.
At some point, journalists started
connecting across borders, too.
During the last decade,
there was a number of groundbreaking,
cross-border investigations
that had dozens of media
organizations working together.
“Panama Papers” is probably
one of the most famous
of such cross-border
journalism collaborations.
It had more than 100 media working on it;
it affected countries on every continent.
More importantly, it led
to more than one billion dollars
to be recovered to the economies
of the countries they were stolen from.
Now let’s take a look at maps
that show which countries were featured
in three major global investigations
from 2016 to 2021.
So this is “Panama Papers,”
“Paradise Papers,”
“Pandora Papers.”
As you can see, some countries
keep being blank spots on these maps,
and one of them is Kyrgyzstan,
my home country.
And does it mean there is no
organized crime in Kyrgyzstan
or maybe no corruption?
No way.
There is a lot of corruption
in my country,
and organized crime
is a pretty powerful force.
Kyrgyzstan was just not covered
in major global investigations
for a very long time.
I’m one of the founders of Kloop,
a very unusual media organization
that I co-founded in Kyrgyzstan
back in 2007 with my friend, Rinat.
Initially it was just a news website
and a journalism school.
We would train journalists
as young as 15 or 16
to cover politics,
human rights violations
and many, many other stories
that happened in our country.
Throughout the years
our journalists grew up,
and by the time they were
in their early 20s,
they thought they were too experienced
to just cover daily news.
They wanted to take on
more involved stories,
and they were eager
to make a difference in Kyrgyzstan.
So we started publishing
bigger investigations
with our young and engaged journalists,
but there were some difficulties though.
In some cases, we did not have
enough resources or experience
to work on very complicated stories,
and sometimes it was just too scary.
For example, once we even
received a death threat
for trying to investigate criminal
activities of the then-president’s son.
And the problem was we didn’t
know who could protect us,
and we eventually had to drop
this investigation.
But then something important
happened in 2017
when we joined the network of OCCRP,
Organized Crime and Corruption
Reporting Project.
It is an organization based in Bosnia.
It was initially formed to unite
the best investigative media outlets
from the Balkans,
and later it expanded its network
to many other countries in Europe
and then to Central Asia,
Middle East, Africa, Latin America.
And the goal of this
organization is in its name:
to fight organized crime
and corruption with journalism.
We were the first Central Asian
member of this network,
and oh, how many changes it has brought.
We turned Kyrgyzstan
from a blank spot on the map
into a country where organized crime
and corruption are investigated
as never before.
In 2019, we joined our efforts with OCCRP
and also with Radio Liberty,
a media organization
based in Czech Republic,
and Bellingcat, an Investigative
Center from the UK.
And together we published
a series of investigations
about an underground cargo empire.
A secretive family clan that transported
goods from China to Central Asia
and didn’t pay all the taxes and tariffs,
if you know what I mean.
In order to do that,
they bribed the Kyrgyzstan
Customs Service,
and a significant chunk of this bribe
went to this person:
Raimbek Matraimov,
the Deputy Head of Kyrgyzstan’s Customs.
Our investigations revealed
that even high-ranking officials
in Kyrgyzstan are involved in corruption,
poisoning their whole institutions
with the worst possible practices.
People in Kyrgyzstan were outraged
when they read this,
and this led to an unprecedented
chain reaction.
So first there were protests
in Kyrgyzstan
because of what was published
in the investigation itself.
A year later, in 2020,
even larger protests happened
when some of the politicians
who were featured in our investigations
had their party taking second place
in the Parliament elections.
As a result of these larger protests,
Parliament election results were annulled,
government was changed
and eventually the president
of the country was forced to resign.
(Applause)
But this investigation was important
not only for Kyrgyzstan.
Remember I told you about this family clan
that started this scheme
in the first place?
They earned a lot of money
in Central Asia.
We revealed and had evidence
of at least 800 million dollars
that went through their business,
and the real figure might be even higher.
And where exactly
did they spend their money?
Well, they bought this house
in Los Angeles, California,
and this mansion in the UK;
they started a construction project
in Augsburg, Germany;
they bought many apartments in Dubai.
In other words,
there is probably no such thing
as local organized crime investigation.
Because of how
organized crime is structured,
almost every investigative story about it
has at least a regional significance,
and in many cases
it has a global significance.
So now there are several messages
that I want to deliver today.
Message number one:
journalism networks are actually
very efficient and important.
You don’t need 100 media organizations
for every investigation.
You know, like in our case,
we only had four,
and it was already a huge game-changer.
And for local media
organizations like Kloop,
this is also a safety measure.
As I mentioned before,
working on investigations alone is scary.
Within our network we not only
share knowledge or resources,
but we also care about each other,
and we keep each other secure.
Message number two:
support local media organizations
all around the world.
When global journalism
collaborations first began,
it was mostly media
from Europe or the Americas
that would have a leading role
as they had the greatest resources.
But media organizations from other
continents are very important too.
We have unique expertise,
insights and connections.
Before I move to the third
and final message,
I want to share something
personal with you.
Last year I moved to Ukraine
because Kloop planned to start
a new regional media project there,
and we are now forced
to do it in another country
because this man was belligerent
enough to invade Ukraine,
the country that became my second home.
But I want to highlight
a role of another country in this war:
Belarus.
Belarus is very corrupt.
It has been run by Alyaksandr Lukashenka,
a dictator that has been ruling
this country since the 1990s.
Lukashenka did something unthinkable.
He provided the territory of Belarus
to the Russian army
to attack Ukraine from the north.
One of the similarities
between Belarus and Kyrgyzstan
is that both our countries are small
and get little attention
from global media.
At the same time,
for decades, local media in Belarus
did not have enough resources
or safety measures to thoroughly
investigate Lukashenka
and corrupt officials around him.
The thing is, Lukashenka is not
really a super powerful leader
of global magnitude.
Unlike Putin, he could [have
been] weakened years ago.
What helped him stay in power
was massive pressure on civil society,
on local media
and lack of financial measures
from other countries.
If the global community
took stronger action against Lukashenka,
if local media were stronger
and better linked with global networks,
I believe Russia could have lost
its key ally a long, long time ago.
A better-timed collaborative journalism
investigation could save many lives.
So here I come to my final message.
Let's leave criminals and corrupt
officials without access to their money
before it’s [too late].
This is where journalists
need help from activists,
politicians
and even bankers,
not just from each other.
We must expand our cross-border networks
outside of the media world too,
because every exposed, corrupt official,
every arrested organized crime leader
is a chance to protect our world
not only from smugglers and thieves,
but also from dictators
and warmongers.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)